before this video begins i need to
remind you guys the biggest sale of g
fuel of the year is going on right now
where you buy one you get one
yeah here if there's ever time to stock
up now's your chance or if you haven't
tried it this is a great way to try
different flavors there's so many great
flavors uh you get the pewdiepie black
edition now the original flavor tastes
amazing everyone loves it we also have a
new shaker cup these always sell out so
if you want one check it out link is the
description yeah this is a limited offer
so make sure you take advantage of it
now
it doesn't get better than this they
also have two new flavors one is their
mystery classified flavor with a world
war ii theme could it be call of duty
related
what does call of duty flavor tastes
like i don't know but it will be amazing
because it's g fuel and they all taste
amazing the flavor is classified however
until further notice they also have a
raspberry pie flavor oh that sounds good
i haven't even tried them use the link
in the description this is a limited
offer buy one get one it doesn't get
better than this so i want you guys to
take advantage of it anyway i'll put a
video
we're watching this video 52 million in
a day
i won't then all right i haven't
actually watched it it's not even number
one in trending what does it take to get
them trending then if you don't 52
million in a day that's not good enough
does it sell your souls to the devil
kind of views mr beasley what did you do
created every single set from squid game
in real life in whichever one of these
456 people survives the longest wins 456
grand
oh he actually remade squid game a
replica
he got 400 oh he got 400.
the first game we're going to play is
red light green light and they have 30
minutes to cross the red line on the
other side of the huge room so does he
shoot them
mr beast would kill without further ado
green light
red light
[Music]
and as you can see every single player
has a device strapped to them that when
they're eliminated no i could not
definitely not see that they look like
he wished himself or they yeah i should
say anyway i remember people said the
thing with squid game that made it look
surreal is that they actually had this
many actors but it looks super cramped
dude
[Music]
how do they spot everyone for sure this
guy moved green light
you'd have to keep an eye on every
single person how would you even
do this okay now some people are getting
out you got to get a better spot for the
next red leg right
you're fine 30 people have gotten out so
far
oh bro you're so nervous
i hope we win move right now they're out
they have to hold this position until we
say green light and i can take all the
time i want because we still have 23
minutes left we should get a green light
going this guy's doing a full squat
green light
green light oh they all stop
oh got played dude
oh
no glasses off okay do it slowly though
be careful
okay are you good yeah perfect green
light
uh she's moving her lips uh oh hey
what are you doing she was jogging over
here we're gonna go see who's in the
very back you are in dead last what's
going on i'll let the others clear the
path for me green light
yellow
red light
that we got her the yellow light you
don't want to be first
was a big part of the show i'll let you
say green light green light
red light
yeah it would be funny if she just got
out
as you can see over 100 people have been
eliminated
how bad can you be so easy it's a
childless game come on green light
red light
oh that was a loud one
there it is hey
green light
how do they keep track on all of them
it's 400 people how do you know if some
of them moved i don't get it how's it
possible
that guy's literally crabbing
my face
then there's so many people there
they gotta run faster they've gotta
you've gotta spray oh they're so down
[Applause]
i'm not even gonna say
i'm not
too safe
[Music]
damn jesus christ this is crazy it looks
like he just turned up after they shot
the series and was like all right can i
use this set
congrats
if you look at this tv you'll see that
only
232 of you survived i thought for sure
he would spread this out to like a bunch
a series a bunch of episodes nah my
dudes put it in one reveal number one
so they don't know which one they're
getting okay cool but bro it doesn't
matter if they watch the show they know
they just suck on it and you're good
look how happy they are
chris
we got the circle thank god we didn't
get the umbrella hey six nine that's six
nine right there that's number six nine
i knew it thank god we didn't get the
umbrella okay guys we're getting my
middle man oh my god you look pretty
nervous over here even though you got
the star you're the main character so
you have plot armor you're fine
that's true
the challenge is underway
i really want to play this game
all right
oh
they caught it
nice yeah that's satisfying how do they
even like keeping track of this many
people well logistically i'm just like
how i was taking it out of the ten and
it just snapped in half let's see it
oh bruh
it's working get an umbrella yeah i'm
sorry bud i wonder what happens someone
just tackles chris steals his ipad and
just goes
explosive
just me all right we have a successful
triangle congratulations thank you but
jimmy doesn't know cause i brought a
lighter and i'm gonna drop it for
somebody just like the show he did a
thing what what
[Music]
one and a half minutes looks like it was
through something else don't worry
oh my gosh this is the first perfect
umbrella i've seen
it looks so gross they've like been
sucking and smoking on it i'm
six seven okay she passed she does have
plot armor
she really seems like she cares some
people are so hyped to be there
otherwise it's like whatever i don't
know
are you serious yes
[Music]
time is up you did it you did the
umbrella and just like that all these
players have been eliminated but don't
worry because they're all walking away
with two thousand dollars but don't
worry they all get to go on the slide i
want to go on that slide it looks
awesome actually doesn't
they just welded a bunch of pieces
together okay
142 of you survived honeycomb
and if you leave in the next five
minutes i'll give you four thousand
dollars let's weed out some of the weak
people four thousand dollars
i'm not expecting this many people okay
damn they needed to clear out some
people huh
split up into groups of ten we have them
form teams because next up is tug of war
four o'clock just to leave if i didn't
that was the deal in life hey just for
crying you can leave we're trying to
recruit the biggest people so we can get
real strong and pull the rope
yeah they know what's that yeah yeah
they know what they're uh what's coming
up
[Music]
i should have taken the four grand we
now have 12 different groups of 10.
now let's decide who faces who
okay we're gonna draw one from here six
we'll just draw this one five okay
follow me to the bridge
i know are they actually up higher a
game of talk of war team six versus team
five c5 that seems logistically uh
necessary and dangerous no they're not
that bad come on the other team side
it's cg it's cbi guys
[Music]
like in a
strip club
dance pole or something what's happening
congratulations team five you have all
moved on
team number two versus team number seven
[Applause]
oh it's already on right side hey let's
check in on zero six seven and the show
you won so let's see if it works here
and carl we have zero six seven you
should just lose oh no give a motivation
wait a minute wait a minute what was
happening there what's going on
underneath are they actually going up
what are they falling by i'm too dumb
for this
nine versus eleven
why are they
team 11 they went so hard that this
happened
they broke the set
throughout this entire challenge we've
been monitoring who you've been talking
to the most people who don't have
monitoring stuff
and only one of you can move on for
example zero six seven and four three
and do you think anyone is sleeping in
those beds because they don't look
comfortable
that's my best friend
yeah kill her kill her yeah
according to this you two are roommates
and best friends we did our research i
have to come home to the house we live
in at the end of the day i'm gonna be a
bit awkward i wouldn't be able to do it
without you we couldn't have done it
without each other i'm glad i'm with you
at the end everybody gets a bag of 10
marbles and they have to agree on a game
to play it against their best friend 20
marbles lets them move on easy i'm the
guy with the glasses that kills everyone
eliminate their best friend go ahead and
start the timer you can play whatever
game you want you need 20 to leave a lot
of pairs went with marvel games that
were played in sweet games
[Music]
yeah i never understand the odd thing i
don't i still don't understand how that
game
and other groups got creative what is
this game we're throwing it at the
bricks right if you get the middle one
right there that's one point if you hit
the bricks in the behind fence three
points everything else
[Music]
i love this smile i'm like i don't
really get it
that's too relatable
but one group just wanted to get it over
with you're doing even odds for all of
it yo he looks so intense
yeah i mean why drag it out
oh he got it oh my gosh
congratulations on winning i'll see you
in the next round nice
you're good okay
[Music]
i think william osman designed those
things i'm not sure if that's true or
not but that's dope it doesn't hurt
they really went into all the details so
crazy that subscribes the next seven
days is getting 10 000 uh that applies
for me as well if you subscribe you
could
you could
win 10 grand
can i get sued for saying that
you could
let's make him what you could win a
million subscribe now you could win a
million
you could
win a million
you're literally both about to get
eliminated
what was that he took one for the team
you sure that's some animation
wow
what the legend
how extra paced
love it the time has hit zero everyone
in here is eliminated
congratulations every time i see her she
just seemed unbothered what is happening
in the real show there was an all-out
brawl to thin the numbers so instead
we're gonna play dachy you have to use
this blue piece of paper to flip that
red one on the ground by throwing it the
first sixteen of you to follow everybody
it's impossible personally my favorite
this is where i would die yeah
i'm gonna have to eliminate you
oh that was so in sync oh my gosh now
can all of you winners turn around thank
you
and now you can turn around again we
just filled the room with 16 different
mannequins and here's the thing they're
actually in a random order and the
numbers oh it's time for the braves the
number they get here is what order they
have to cross and glass bridge in a
timely and orderly fashion you can all
go
okay
first come first serve what'd you get oh
she got one oh
dean
right you want to just go ahead and
leave now
all right she survived just walk on the
edge just won't come out for one so far
okay i don't know if i'd listen to chris
chris is on you hey victory
if you're wondering where she just fell
don't worry there's a giant foam pit
down there she's fine damn it
now you know now you know left
13 minutes guys i didn't even do that
three people on the platform only one
out so far
are they allowed to push each other
[Music]
yes
now you go all right come on dude you
got this
see what do they do if they
all die i guess that's squid game for
you
that's kind of cool you got it hey if no
one crosses i just keep the money all
right three months
but like clearly they have to wait for
them to be like okay now we're gonna
send them dan if you want to win just
keep going there he's just one minute
remaining hey you guys in the back if
you're not here when it hits here you're
gone all right i took my leap of faith
no i'm gonna stay right here and be cozy
hurry go y'all go it's just three
[Applause]
they're in my way they're in my way
they're all crowded all day yeah
second go
one more i already jumped i'm not
jumping i'm not jumping
[Music]
the four people were 16 8 13 and five
all right so the four losers can you
jump cool i don't like that
yeah
get out of here call me carson yeah
thank you for coming out now unlike the
show this isn't a real knife this is
plastic but but what if the epic
pescetarian you do have sticks everyone
make sure you eat up so you have plenty
of energy for this final game i'm
thinking about winning all of that money
right now can you tell
hey the voice
is going down here they must have worked
so hard
or filmed so long now unlike the show
this isn't a real knife you hear it
right his voice he's been yelling all
day god bless him
you do have steak everyone make sure you
eat up so you have plenty of energy for
this final game
totally busted i'll probably give most
of it to my family definitely donating
about 10 000 to team c's which all of
you should if you have the means i won't
fold on no pressure i'm not worried
about none of these fog ain't nobody got
nothing on me so i'm good you want to
just go settle this with the final game
that's why we're doing musical chairs
instead because we're not korean start
circling start the music
carl you can stop it whenever you want
carl do not look chris don't look carl
isn't looking so we can't be biased
all right let's see what happens
oh oh he got it i got more man
sorry about that
oh no
bringing the coffin over here hop on in
the coffin he has officially been nice
this chair is now gone
[Music]
dude they're sweating they want that
cash goddamn come over here
[Music]
yeah okay okay good good yeah and while
they're coughing him up play the music
okay
the music has to be gone oh man oh you
said oh yeah wait is that early he sat
early carl did not stop the music bring
out the coffin he died i didn't know
that was the role
to go out it was a great journey i loved
it it was so fun hop on it
all right now you can't say this is
scripted
with the chair
the music has started three people two
chairs one are you wearing banana peels
what's happening keep it moving no you
got to keep moving got to keep moving
[Music]
oh
no
yes
they were against me they were against
me bro
they plotted on me carl's not looking at
them he has no idea where they are on
the chair
the car's not funny where he is a
thousand dollars because you pause the
music oh boy
oh this is something
way more that cool
when's he gonna
[Music]
dude half a million dollars
that's insane
if it makes you feel better i'm gonna
give you ten thousand dollars
about something
about half a
oh mill
silly pissed
dude look at all that money huge
inspiration from the show and i
genuinely appreciate you goodbye
well yeah
that was lit that was really cool anyway
subscribe and you can win
you could win
a billion